[Music]
I've been shot on the street stabbed in
prison been a victim of a slashing twice
actually dead in the morgue died in a
supermarket from overeating my name is
Ali murky i am a actor and i have played
a dead body on several occasions the
director usually tells you to hold still
try your best to hold your breath it's
good to slow your breathing down
beforehand kind of like yoga or
meditation played a corpse in the morgue
on law and order laying down on cold
metal while you know you're practically
wearing nothing is in it's bone-chilling
and to say the least you can take short
breaths but they still don't want to see
your chest going up and down at a
distance they're like in a second you
sure that guy's dead back there is
breathing whenever you end up dying on
camera or playing dead on camera it
brings you to another emotional state
normally people don't think if I was
shot or stabbed what would I do but once
you're there and you're playing it it's
kind of a little traumatic you feel bad
for people when you see real people get
hurt you take it in a different you know
you see it in a different way you know
my kids watch it sometimes and they're
like dad you're dead they killed you
like no I'm here with you no I'm okay
[Music]